[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you all so much for
being here to be a part of tonight is
amazing welcome it's so cool to get to
do a show not only with four women but
with three of my best friends so thank
you for being a part of tonight give
yourself a meal people always assume
that I'm shallow cuz I'm really pretty
but no I'm really not I'm not shallow at
all like the guy I'm seeing right now
isn't even good-looking Amy Schumer is
not funny
hi how's it going bros it's your boy
PewDiePie I have a level 12 white knight
and I'm here to defend Amy Schumer from
all you all to write hateful white male
angry Amy Schumer it's the greatest
comedian of all time you guys just don't
understand Amy Schumer like I do you
don't understand her comedy when Amy
Schumer says mother Johnna she's not
just saying my vagina she's saying
something deeper damn it
vagina vagina vagina vagina just do
women's comedy stuff you know talk about
how fat you aren't how you want to take
a gadget and say maybe yeah yeah hello
vagina when Amy Schumer is making a
bunch of incoherent babbling and noises
that's the pinnacle of comedy don't you
understand
[Applause]
[Music]
if you don't like Amy Schumer then it's
because you hate women and I'm a level
six respecting of women as everyone
knows me by so this isn't apply to me of
course ticular they apologize from you
know this isn't gonna be a good speech I
make of that where did we how did we get
to that place I think because so many
people hate women
there's so much anger toward women it's
big serious that's right if you don't
find Amy Schumer funny it's because you
hate women take a deep look at yourself
take a deep look into your mind and
think why why am I not laughing at these
funny jokes oh that's right I hate women
[Music]
hilarious so funny sorry I just was busy
laughing at Amy's jokes now I saw Amy
Schumer I was introduced to her maybe
five years ago before she really blew up
and she really wasn't as intolerable as
she is today
what happened let's explore it all
started when Amy got accused for
stealing jokes not just once but many
times at least a couple you ever black
out when you're drinking or as I call it
time travel
yeah has anyone ever blacked out and
been awake when they've come out of it
thank you thank you sister
it's kind of cool cuz you're it's like
you're a time traveler you're just like
back in your body like cut balls are
disgusting aren't they Wow and they
stink yeah they go all right I'll speak
for my balls on my best day my balls
might smell like a foot on my best day
my [ __ ] smells like a small barnyard
animal okay you want to hear the same
jokes from other comedians being told in
a less funny way just watch Amy Schumer
everyone the examples goes on and on
there's literally dozens I don't want to
keep being repeating myself you get the
point but stealing jokes is just the
worst thing you could possibly do and I
can even fathom the thought process that
would go through someone to sink that
low to steal someone else's ideas but
they worked hard on that they spend
their soul and passion into to just get
ripped off by someone else less funny
how could you do that
how could anyone sink so low anyway have
you guys seen my latest of The Wire
episode by the way check it out think
you'll like it
aimer had to brush off these allegations
by saying no I did not steal Chuck even
though there's evidence of me saying I
watched these comedy specials himself
maybe she didn't do it intentionally I
don't know I don't really care but it's
what started Amy's downward spiral for
upward spiral of her giant massive ego
when her Netflix special came out the
funniest thing that ever has ever been
released by the way I'd literally died
and came back from watching it or at
least I wish I'd died I watched the
whole thing I'm not
joking I've seen some [ __ ] but in case
you haven't seen it here it is
summarized [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] it
was getting so many down votes that it
literally had one star rating on Netflix
remember what Netflix used to had star
as ratings which was a useful way to for
you to find out what you could watch
else based on recommendations well they
took that off because Amy Schumer's
Netflix special just had such low
ratings that it was just too much to
bear so what did Amy have to say about
why her special got such low rating well
she basically blamed the alt right
that's right the reason why my comedy
special didn't do well it's not because
I'm not funny
it's because she spend the wheel at home
[Music]
doesn't like me yes of course Amy hello
in case you are watching you have a
massive ego problem and it's time for
you to deal with it and I not touch it
yeah I know that you just want to brush
this off and call me alright or anything
like that but I think it would really
help you to just admit that there's
something wrong it would be great just
just take the first step please because
you're just going more and more down
when you're faced with criticism you can
either accept it disapprove of it or you
can say ah no it's because you hate
women or because you belong to this
political group this is the problem that
a lot of celebrities with massive egos
have when they're faced with criticism
it's always everyone else's fault
it can never be themselves and which
leads them to just go batshit insane and
they rationalize this theory in their
head of why you're faced with criticism
and that's why they just they lose it
Amy you've lost it it's pretty come up I
think the reason why I'm so annoying
with Amy is that she's hiding behind
this banner of social justice and that
she's such a great person you know but
she's literally just like everyone else
which is fine by the way but she's got a
person that L if someone calls her fat
it's a huge deal and you're body shaming
but she literally bought a shame other
people for being too skinny recently it
came out that Amy wanted to be paid just
as much as her male comedians like Davey
Chappelle and Chris Rock apparently she
was only paid half for her Netflix
special Oh boohoo
I see this being done a lot in
entertainment field where people compare
male and female and say oh well this
person made this much and this person
they made this much why aren't they
making the same salary they're both
female just because they're different
genders that's the reason why they're
not making the same amount no it's
because people didn't like your show Amy
people didn't like your special
Dave Chappelle's special is one of the
best comedy specials of the year unlike
yours which flop you have to understand
that it's not about gender here but of
course that's the reason why because it
can never be you Amy it's ever always
someone else isn't it my comprehension
if if Trump won it's just it's too crazy
if it isn't Hillary November does you'll
act changed as you'll my actual change
because I'll need to learn to speak
Spanish because I will move to Spain or
somewhere Amy have you heard of Saudi
Arabia I think you would love it there's
no one Trump there please go
sincerely everyone have a great time
[Applause]
you in rats typical Swedes look at them
here's the thing if someone get heckled
you're supposed to make a fool out of
them by making a joke that's not a joke
it's not a joke she's incapable of
coming up with a joke on the spot
[Music]
[Applause]
my god Oh sweets men buzz light party
here to discuss equal pay women don't
get paid as much as men and that is
wrong and we have to pay more for the
same stuff what yeah cars
what dry-cleaning what shampoo what you
pay more but get paid less than as
double wrong I'm calling everyone I know
that is wrong and we have to pay more
for the same stuff what no you don't you
don't have to pay more why are you lying
imagine trying to stand up for the
women's movement by getting paid for for
promoting beer and then just spewing a
bunch of lies are you kidding me what I
never thought of that that have I told
you about my chair by the way I know
what a great price it costs the same if
you're a boy and a girl you might think
excuse me we're not so progressive
liberal Amy Schumer if you're a woman
get this this chair cost 399 dot zero
you're welcome women across the nation
and think brave people like Amy Schumer
for making what is already possible
possible she got paid to do this by the
way just letting you know just letting
you know but honestly you call yourself
a comedian but you don't do it that much
like I go fishing a couple times a year
but I don't introduce myself on TV as a
fisherman Wow
oof oh so that means just because I
[ __ ] the donkey once I am NOT a donkey
[ __ ] thank you Amy Schumer that means
a lot basically what these two are
talking about is when you should first
have sex in a relationship and he's he's
saying you should wait a little bit more
and she's saying well it doesn't matter
you should just have sex right away and
she's very confident about this kind of
being like well I'm older than you and
you're stupid
which each lasted between two to five
years we stuck with each other almost
immediately and it's because I knew that
I wanted to be with them you know
what a great case for lasting
relationships man I think my favorite
Amy Schumer clip probably the funniest
thing she's ever done is when she
literally steals a joke from aim from
Ellen DeGeneres and then tells it to
Ellen DeGeneres it's absolutely
brilliant let's watch I look like I've
been feeding and I'm eating popcorn the
way I think we all eat popcorn which is
you know at first time you always kind
of start out kind of like lying to
yourself like oh like one piece at a
time you know and then and then like you
get a little more real right and then
eventually you just like you get real
real and it's just good and something
about the darkness we just lose all of
our inhibitions in the darkness is the
popcorn really that delicious we must
shovel handfuls of it into our mouths
she was popcorn like that though when
she was growing up everybody laughed
when Amy Schumer said she wanted to be a
comedian nobody's laughing now that's it
for me about Amy Amy if you watch I hope
you enjoyed please leave a thumbs up and
as always keep on Mirjana her brofist